la grave desnutrición que padece ha
hecho que su cuerpo se hinche con apenas
tres años este niño fue llevado por su
madre y asociaciones a este centro de
mogadicción a 300 kilómetros de su casa
su madre que tiene otros nueve hijos
Dice que no ha podido cosechar nada
desde 2019 por la falta de lluvia
la falta de agua no saber subir para
conseguir un bidón de agua tenemos que
caminar dos horas y antes de poder
volver por el siguiente ya se ha puesto
el sol y no hay nadie que de comer a los
niños
Esta no es la primera temporada de
sequía en el cuerno de África para el
próximo mes será la quinta la mitad de
la población de somalia está
directamente afectada unicef ha
registrado la muerte de más de 700 niños
entre enero y Julio de este año
el número de casos de desnutrición
registrados en los últimos tres meses es
de unos 6000 solo en los siete centros
de mogadicción pero la cifra puede ser
mayor porque los registros no siempre
son precisos
en todo el país más de medio millón de
niños menores de 5 años sufren
desnutrición severa la última hambruna
en 2011 causó 260.000 muertes los
funcionarios locales de la ONU dicen que
la situación está aún peor este año